steven this is a huge honor uh for many
reasons one of which is i can just tell
how much care you put into this
conversation and
um how much you know i use the word love
a lot but i just feel the love
that um just even the respect you give
me which i can't tell you
how energized that is how much that
gives me strength
for my own silly little pursuits
um thank you so much for doing that
thank you for not just talking today but
uh giving me so much respect just with
everything you're doing is i i really
appreciate that it makes me feel special
so thank you so much for sitting down
and talking today mutual lex thank you
as well and thank you for the respect
that you've shown me and these are
really difficult issues that don't have
simple answers
but that doesn't mean we give up
we have to keep thinking and learning
and trying
and finding solutions in everything we
do including on these these big global
tragedies that we live through
and it's heartbreaking
what's going on it it just breaks my
heart every day a person who studies
this has been studying this for decades
and it keeps happening
and you think again
and yes it is again but but we still
have to keep trying and we have to be
inspired by those people who are more
courageous than we are and sacrifice
more than we sacrifice
you know for me
the russian invasion of ukraine the war
in ukraine
is experienced in my study at home
and in my office at princeton or
my coming office at stanford when i move
full time to stanford in september or or
it's experienced far away in safety
and in comfort
and we have to remember that too
when we talk about these things when we
answer your questions right
that as we speak and as we
comment and think we're experts on these
things from the comfort of our existence
that there are people in those tragedies
right now
with no power with no food with no
with full uncertainty about the future
of the house of their
that's it
and uh and i've also seen because i have
family in both places
homes
that
were home for buildings that were homes
for generations
now in rubble
so
yes lex it it just it hurts
and it's it's let's r it's syria
where 350 000 at least by u.n estimates
died
and russia participated in that
and it's yemen
and and it's so many other places that
don't have the same degree of attention
that a european country like ukraine has
but but yeah we have to remember also
that in addition to ukraine
and then there's things right home here
in new york city
where children are without food
which is just inexcusable in a country
this rich
so we shouldn't forget in our study of
leaders in our study of geopolitics that
ultimately it's about the humanity it's
about the human beings and
okay like human suffering thank you so
much thank you this is amazing
conversation talk to you again soon my
pleasure
you